i
love my wife
she loves me i enjoy her company
and i'm never going to apologize for
that
okay everyone hates you we are not the
weird ones
you just grabbed his what no i i dropped
i dropped something
uh hello ma'am i work for the city
every few years we encounter someone
with a
defect you have sex 2.5 times a day on
average
you rarely fight ah
after the injections you will wake up
tomorrow
just like everyone else you'll feel
normal
i don't want to be here where do you
want to go i don't know anywhere
hi karen if you guys are so interested
we'd love for you to come
what are we gonna do we have to pretend
like nothing ever happened
never showed up to our door
hey the first couple has arrived who
wants a tour
how about this one oh that's not a
bedroom
so there's a gun room we're gonna have a
killer weekend
it's party time oh my god
we are out of booth i could totally do a
quick booze run
gretel yeah
don't you ever want something different
tell me the truth
baby there is something wrong with us
does this briefcase look familiar to
anyone
somebody is watching us question why are
we still here
nice to bro there's nothing wrong with
us
this is lovely okay it's not working
i need to figure out the game i'm gonna
pop this [ __ ]
is he breathing
[Music]
you